نشد ناجون فلسطينيون كانوا عالقين في
مدرسه الشهيد محمد الدره بمنطقه قيزان
النجار في خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه نشدوا
الصليب الاحمر التدخل لانتشال خمسه شهداء
من عائله واحده ما تزال جثامينهم داخل
المدرسه التي تاوي نازحين وروى الناجون
الذين تمكنوا من الوصول الى مستشفى ناصر
في خان يونس شهاداتهم بشان اقتحام قوات
اسرائيليه
للمدرسه يا اختي بسدو ايش اللي صار معكم
الساعه ت دخلوا
الدبابات عشوائي
ابعدوا مش قادرين يك نطلع اخويا مات وامي
ماتت خواتي يه ماتوا وانا وجوزي بخير
واختي
تاوب ايش تركتي وراك في ناس متصاوب مش
كتير شهدا في خمس شهداء ابويا وامي ابويا
وامي وخواتي ابويا وامي
وخواتي وين الصليب وين الصليب وين الصليب
يا ناس احل بناشد الدول العربيه احنا
بدناش الدول العربيه بجيب ابويا وامي
وخوات الشهداء في مس محمد
الضره